hey guys welcome back to another video
and today is going to be about the
realistic Dominion game-mode that
released a couple days ago and have it's
really saving for honor or not just by
personal opinion so let's get started so
first off if you don't know what it was
on Thursday Ubisoft said during their
weekly dev stream recap they were going
to have a new game mode called realistic
Dominion where it's Dominion with no
gear stats revives HUD org our stance
icon basically realistic mode if you've
ever played the story mode it's pretty
difficult without having a guard stance
and this game mode has seen so many
positive reviews for really how hard it
is everyone on reddit really wants this
game to become a permanent mode and even
want it to spread to other game modes
like elimination duel and brawl this
game mode has taken players back to the
beta days when people dinner they all
combos or what they really knew what to
do and basically just throw out heavies
and lights hoping they would land hits
and stuff like that this mode also makes
Perry's indie flex feel so satisfying
and accomplishing knowing that you can't
see what the movies coming from and the
timing still seems off so it's really a
lot more accomplishing pulling off these
types of moves and if you've played this
mode in the few in the past few days
you'll understand exactly what I'm
talking about
I personally have always been able to
parry Raider zone saying that he doesn't
fainted and actually commits to it but
now I start to fail the parry more often
than ever it's making people relearn
this game slightly and it even allows
people to gain more knowledge on where
an attack is coming from based off
animation for example if you know the
direction where an attack comes from in
realistic Dominion just from animation
you'll know where it's going to come
from in the game when you play the
regular game modes ultimately making you
a better player this game is this game
mode is even better for new players
because like I said previously
everyone's just throwing out moves and
just hoping they even hit something
obviously with the feet you know with
some time players will be back to normal
throwing out more combos and parries and
defects will be a lot more successful
but it takes time for now it's perfect
for new players to play because another
feel like what it's like to play
Dominion without being stomped by a team
with double-digit rep characters and 144
gear score since gear score and that has
been disabled the only problem I really
have
with this game-mode is that certain
characters are a bit better or pick if
you pick them in this game-mode than
others such as shinobi because you can't
see the direction of his long-range
guard break or his long-range sickle
attack and then that certain characters
like valcon pique seemed a lot harder to
block or dodge with their superfast
light attacks especially on console I
don't know how PC players have to deal
with this because with the whole frame
difference 30 frames does help are kind
of determines a lot I guess from what
I'm hearing Valkyrie isn't a problem on
PC with 60 frames but as 30 frames on
councils she's just super deadly but
that's really my only opinion on the
game to be honest is like the only
problem I have let me get to know what
you think about this game-mode
personally I've been enjoying this
game-mode that's really all I've been
playing for the past like three days
hopefully Ubisoft will keep this game is
permanent and then hopefully spread it
to other modes so we can have more of a
chance and more challenge ourselves
where all the game modes you know don't
have ha - the guard stands icon but
we'll have to wait and see if you guys
did enjoy the video please be sure to
like it and if you didn't dislike it and
if you're new subscribe for new for on
our content and I'm always putting out
click the bell right next to it to be
part of the notification squad and never
with someone of my uploads my recent
upload though speaking of that will be
in the top right for you to check out we
did a dead stream recap so this couple
tons of news are going to be talking
about defense meta changes coming in the
PTR some very good high quality
information if you missed it so please
go check that out if you did and with
that guys I hope you all have a great
rest of your day and peace out I'll see
you all later